[Music]
an overworked donking is submitted by
Alito magic that's that got to Casey
good for her talkie I don't know yeah
you picture donkey with a [ __ ] sweat
band on there's working as a life out I
don't even talking she's just their
funny-looking yet the resting faces
overworked so I get it yeah like a dog
thank you yeah thank you
I've seen a little kid riding a donkey
like around in a circle it's like one of
the most depressing things I've ever
seen and the kids having a great time
though that's what matters that's why
it's depressing the kids also probably
wishing he was fighting a horse stuff
nobody wins it's true sure it's for the
parents entertainment kid has no [ __ ]
clue what's going on cuz to a kid a
donkey is like the f ggot of a horse
[ __ ] am i writing this book could you
spell it out doesn't make it any better
why I'm trying to tell you CLA [ __ ]
do supposed to go a donkey is the bag of
the horn any fine what I think that's a
kids thing
Greece is having to breed stronger
donkeys for its scenic tours because of
overweight tourists are sitting on the
donkey and a dog isn't like breaking
their legs and [ __ ] yeah donkeys like
like racism [ __ ] yeah yeah they're very
have like golf carts or something that
could get them up there no I don't know
this but apparently doing a donkey ride
is like the super popular thing to do in
Santorini
oh and so they're not doing it yeah so a
ton of people a ton of tourists this is
like one of their must dude it's like a
traditional thing like riding a donkey
it's not for children no I mean children
probably still write it
but it's like mainly the tourists being
taken into the city like the main square
from like the cruise ships or wherever
donkeys are such a staple in Greek
culture I come out they don't mention
donkeys in Greek mythology I've been
asking that for 15 years nobody's
answering
I googled it talked about Zeus riding a
donkey or anything like that
nope or Hercules they never worship the
donkey one time yeah I don't believe
this
I think donkeys are a new thing I agree
yeah and it's actually really sad
because somebody's dog do you think
they're being crippled they breaking
their ankles and [ __ ]
I guess show me a picture and she's
texting oh my god
oh that doggy looks pretty strong though
yeah all these poor donkeys they get
used up so much oh it's good no time off
I know that's supposed to be sad but
it's kind of funny well will you laugh
at this next photo Gio career I
guarantee it oh yeah it's the back oh
that is so sad they're all can't that
just happened with
over-usage just a lot of [ __ ] like I
thought was gonna be a way fatter chick
on the donkey laughs I was like oh it's
gonna be like a even bigger [ __ ] on the
donkey
yeah that's funny how like they got a
collection of all these fat people on
donkeys and then there's this like PSA
of like fat [ __ ] riding donkeys that's
why they're getting that's not the
reason why is because donkeys are just
being exploited whether they're fat or
not there's a million people riding
donkeys all the [ __ ] bit all the time
they should have a scale and you should
it should be too thick to ride if you're
- you're saying like a lot of these
activist people that are like put a
weight limit on yeah that they should be
putting a weight limit on these donkeys
like these donkey rides and they should
be taken care of better because they
don't get shade they don't get a lot of
shade they don't get a lot of water
these handlers don't treat their donkeys
right and even the saddles they're not
being put on properly that's that's the
real reason not just because it's a few
fat asses like no they are saying that
over the years the tourists have fun
fatter and fatter in fact like heavier
and heavier yeah that's true one of
those girls look like 300 pounds or so
he's a donkey on the donkey the dog it
was so sad because it looked like a
water bottle and a donkey like this yeah
it was like a Disney cartoon the Sultan
on a [ __ ] you know porcupine or
whatever they made the donkey look like
teacup donkeys like what do you call
those [ __ ] when they compact up your
teeth right there right yeah they
[ __ ] that's sad man yeah how
insulting would that be there you go and
you're through fat you cannot ride a
donkey if you're bigger than the animal
you shouldn't be on that animal I think
it's pretty objective like you're gonna
hurt my animal I'm sorry okay well maybe
they need tourism so bad you can make
money so bad make money I mean yeah I
know but maybe even if I'm too tall they
should be like I'm sorry you're too tall
maybe like all right I get it
I got no argument several years ago with
an X's mother because she was like I
think like the horse and carriage thing
is wrong because those horses have to do
that all day and I'm like dude like what
the [ __ ] else is a horse gonna like how
is a horse first of all horses need to
be fed a lot right so how does a horse
like make sense for somebody to take
care of if they can't make money off of
the horse and like that's one of the
ways you can make what have four and
she's like I'm curious is wrong but I'm
like no you have to we have to consider
the economy of having a home right so
I'm trying to do that here where I'm
like the economy of this is like these
people are trying to make money so they
can get by and feed their families and
ship but they're mistreating the share
of these animals and so that's where I
think yeah I think it's the unethical
mistreatment of this situation where
it's like oh man you're not even [ __ ]
feeding them and taking care of them
right
yellow and it just it's just the [ __ ]
the top of Ville is just right and you
letting these fat people ride them yeah
so now they're saying that they're
resorting to using crossbred mules
because like that's gonna make it better
because they are stronger than donkeys
big big ankles they could do the 300
pounders if donkeys could do sick tricks
we wouldn't even need to ride them cuz
they can pay for themselves doing sick
asterisks like Shamu like well horses
control the shano's what are the horses
can do tricks and they still get your
[ __ ] excuse me
Shamu is a multi-million dollar multi
billion saying it but I'm just saying
dude that Shamu Shamu could get a [ __ ]
ton of people into an area and they'd be
taking money to be legit sad about that
move being gone and I'm sure no no Joe
no I did a million times
no that's whole lot of people to share
the same childhood that I [ __ ] hate
you get sprayed by [ __ ] I sure did
[ __ ] exploitation
I hated it you hated Shamu I hated all
of them did you know that when Shamu
when Shamu is pushing that like he's
jumping on the water and hitting that
ball with his nose he loves it he thinks
it's fun you can talk to Shamu no no a
scientist researched it and he said
today he's had he never has more fun
just saying I just Mel was at the front
row I can't wait everyone had [ __ ]
raincoats on I'm like [ __ ] me get me I'm
like then I can walk around the park
yeah all wet and it's hot day two I
don't know if they still do a killer
whale show but this was about five years
ago I went to SeaWorld and there was but
it was not the same it was so lame they
were just like going up and dancing they
couldn't have the person there anymore
because yeah they don't do the flips and
[ __ ] like multiple times and they're
like they're like baby killer whales
they're smaller they're not they're not
shampoo is [ __ ] like big see what
it's existed for like 60 years and that
only nearly killed like 20 trainers or
something that's pretty good yeah it's a
pretty good number
come on think about it one killer well
dead 20 humans I think it's pretty good
that's the reason why they banned it I
think it was a stupid documentary yeah
is that blackfish documentary that
propaganda what it was all I'm saying is
okay I don't even know if you're kidding
anymore you grew up with bears juggling
three-piece suits with the top hat we've
give up with elephants [ __ ] holding
trunk and [ __ ] tail and going in
circles on a ball oh thank you monkey on
a unison yeah [ __ ] Tigers jumping
through hoops I think you're remembering
cartoons dude this is a [ __ ] movie
Bailey the [ __ ] fiction in real life
right now humor how much fun the lion
had when the tamers like
[Laughter]
there's a lot of fun to that you have
the circus and the zoo they're all gone
now I can't do no sea roll now what's
next - now you go there there's a
jellyfish okay what's next
actually Disney all those costume [ __ ]
walking around they're bitching because
that's 125 degrees in that suit well
guess what
pretty soon thanks to all y'all we're
not gonna take our kid to Disneyland and
however I can take a picture of Mickey
now because Mickey needs rights and
Mickey's - bit too sad because he didn't
heat stroke and you they kind of like
all the older Mickey's are dying early
because they're in the suits for so long
robots imagine that think back to Chuck
E Cheese and all those back when I love
Chuck E Cheese so do you
those guys were so scary Oh Chuckie
Cheese the Chucky Cheese worked what's
that are you on what are you defending
on the side of morally right Chuckie
Cheese he works in an AC room and that's
okay Mickey Mouse works under the Sun
and that's any gonna be in the Sun yeah
it's inhumane
sir boy we're all the same thing I'm
just saying that Shamu those were cool
shows and it's it's too bad no it's not
too bad I'm great there's no more Shamu
are you happy about that I am what else
is kind of Shamu though a Chinese
restaurant he still watches console
tragedies grocery store
[Music]
for me was the petting zoo yeah you know
how kids go to the query me puckett
start touching all that [ __ ] that was me
my just go on the blue-crab section I
put all them on the floor oh my motor
back five crabs climbed all to all these
people who are sad about Shamu you know
what every single fish of the charity
store wishes their chambers day I'll say
that right now I'll say that right now
I'll give that to you
[Music]